[Music]
but secondly these simple thoughts of
good and bad are likewise immediately
self alienated their actual and are
present in actual consciousness as
objective moments thus the first essence
is state power the other is wealth as
state power is a simple substance so -
is it the universal work the absolute
part of the matter itself in which
individuals find their essential nature
expressed and where their separate
individuality is merely a consciousness
of their universality it is also the
work and the simple result from which
the sense that it results from their
doing has vanished it remains the
absolute foundation and subsistence of
all that they do this simple ethereal
substance of their life is in virtue of
this determination other unchangeable
self-identity mere being and in addition
merely a being for another it is thus
directly the opposite of itself well
although this is indeed something
passive something devoid of inner worth
it is equally the perpetually produced
result of the labor and activity in all
just as it is dissipated again in the
enjoyment of all it is true that in the
enjoyment the individuality develops an
awareness of himself as a particular
individual but this enjoyment itself is
the result of the general activity just
as reciprocally wealth produces
universal labour and enjoyment for all
the actual has simply the spiritual
significance of being immediately
universal each individual is quite sure
that he is acting in his own interest
when seeking this enjoyment for it is in
this that he becomes conscious of his
own independent existence and for that
reason does not take it to be something
spiritual yeah even when looked at from
an external point of view it is evident
that
his own enjoyment provides enjoyment for
all just as in working for himself he is
at the same time working for all and all
are working for him his being for
himself is therefore in itself universal
and his self-interest is something
merely in his mind something that cannot
get as far as making a reality of what
it means to do that is to do something
that would not benefit all
here in paragraph 494 Hegel is now going
to introduce two new terms for what we
haven't up till this time calling
spiritual or ethical substance we're
going to have a polarity between state
power stocks mock right sounds kind of
nice right and wealth right to them
riches so we have a duality occurring
within the the spiritual substance and
individuality z-- relation to it just
earlier we saw Hegel talking about
consciousness coming to terms with the
the good and the bad and we're gonna see
him much later introducing you know the
noble and the base you know the gute and
the schlecht
here is going to become transmuted into
state power and and wealth not quite so
directly in in this paragraph it almost
looks as if at the beginning here
he's leaving that behind he says these
simple thoughts of good and bad are
likewise immediately self alienated that
is what appeared to be so simple what
appeared to be something that we could
take as a criterion moving forward is is
not quite so so straightforward and
simple it's going to present itself to
us in a different way we have good and
bad when we're thinking in terms of pure
consciousness when we're looking at
actual view cleek consciousness we have
something else that is very quick
something that we can look at something
that we can experience something that we
can orient ourselves in relation to so
he calls these objective moments these
are present in actual consciousness now
that's an interesting thing to talk
about does he mean that they're there as
mere ideas present in actual
consciousness no these are things
motivate us these are things that we can
you might say internalize these are
things that form the landscape of our
moral environment and thereby become
parts of or shapes within our own
consciousness as individuals as actual
consciousness it also is worth
reflecting that this is a struggle that
Hegel is going to see taking place not
only in the ancient period and the
medieval period but but going through
into the modern period as well so he
says the first essence that we're
talking about here is state power right
the the power of the state the Stott
smocks right and the second is wealth as
state power he says is the simple
substance so to is it the universal work
and here you see I'm talking about the
heart of the matter the Zaca all right
the thing that earlier on we were
calling the project the the central
thing that that the consciousness in its
action Orient's itself around and by and
towards in which it finds its meaning
and state power can in fact provide us
with that kind of locus of meaning we've
seen this taking place already earlier
in the clash between the law of the
community the human law and the law of
the family the divine law right the
human law had to take place through some
sort of government and we could easily
identify ourselves with that in part
because it was manifest and so Hegel
here is going to talk about this as
presenting us with a substantiality he
goes on and he says this is the heart of
the manner in which individuals find
their essential nature expressed and
where their separate individuality is
merely a consciousness of their
universality so in aligning them
with or understate power the individuals
thereby find a universality by which
they can make sense of who they are and
what it is that they're doing and what
their purpose is even if they are
themselves in a position where they are
alienated they're still also able to in
a certain way identify with the state or
at least the interests of the state and
this could be happening in a tyranny
this could be happening in a democracy
this could be happening in all sorts of
regimes the key thing here is that it is
indeed the power of the state the
capacities what it is that the state
does we see this even going on today
with you know ways in which human beings
understand patriotism
which is sort of an imaginary
identification effective relationship to
the state but also in how they align
themselves to the people who represent
state power to them every everybody from
the police to the to the mail carrier to
the people at the Department of Motor
Vehicles to you know the IRS the
Internal Revenue Service for those of
you who aren't here in the States one of
the most powerful branches of our
government right there's there's all
sorts of ways in which this can can take
place so he goes on and he says the
individuals find their nature expressed
in that they find that they're the
separate individuality is merely a
consciousness of their universality then
he goes on he says it's also the work
and the simple result from which the
sense that it results from they're doing
has vanished it remains the absolute
foundation and subsistence of all that
they do the state transcends the
individual the state provides an
overarching meaning to the life of the
individual within it you know you might
think here of examples within philosophy
like in Plato's credo where the laws of
Athens which are about to kill
Socrates are represented by Socrates
himself in argument with credo who has
bought out the guards and has bribed
them and is ready to take Socrates
somewhere safe Socrates himself says no
no no I I exist within a social matrix I
exist in relation to the political
authority which is more than just the
guy who happens to be in charge
the laws transcend us the laws are
greater than us what do we have on the
other side here's where Hegel talks
about wealth he says the simple ethereal
substance of their life the life of the
individual in relation to state power is
in virtue of this determination of their
unchangeable self-identity mere being in
addition merely being for another so
over on this side we have being in
itself on this side we have being for
another he says it's directly the
opposite of itself that is wealth and
this is an interesting way of depicting
it this is not usually how we think
about wealth although this is something
that is a feature of it that has been
discussed within classical philosophy
typically within the scope of the
question of whether wealth is the true
good whether wealth brings us happiness
or not you see Cicero discussing this in
the stoic paradoxes you see Boethius
discussing this in the consolation of
philosophy very important point wealth
is not what it appears to be it is
something more and here we can see
within Hegel at least in this section a
kind of prefiguration of the sort of
economic analysis that somebody like a
young Marx will carry out and indeed the
later Marx right so he says it's the
opposite of itself wealth and he says
although this is indeed something past
wealth is something devoid of inner work
it is equally the perpetually produced
results of the labor and activity of all
just as it is dissipated again in the
enjoyment of all so what we have in
wealth is something dynamic by
comparison to what we might call this if
we want to be paradoxical the static
Dyna Missa tee of the state power wealth
itself involves circulation it involves
production it involves consumption and
all of this at the same time it's not as
if there's a single cycle where first
it's produced and that it circulates and
then it's consumed no there's always
some wealth that is being created at the
same time that other wealth is being
consumed and is circulating in between
different people and each each
individual is able to take part in this
according to Hegel finds a kind of
meaning should we say or at least
occupation within it so he says in the
enjoyment the individual individuality
develops an awareness of itself as a
particular individual but this enjoyment
is the result of the general activity so
there's a kind of universality going on
with this side as well what does he mean
here I I understand who and what I am
through enjoyment through desire and
satisfaction of desire through buying
things you know I I can find out that I
like you know certain kinds of beer and
I don't like other kinds of beer by
trying them out by drinking them by
consuming them there maybe there's a
quired taste right maybe I start with
you know Miller Genuine Draft I don't
think that's really great stuff and then
I have some better things you know some
some nice IPA and some maybe some
Guinness and that I'm like well MGD
isn't quite so good right or I do this
in comparison to other things maybe I do
it who knows with with chalk you know
this chalk is really nice chalk compared
to the other stuff all rights on the
so smoothly it doesn't make that squeaky
sound it isn't light in the hand and and
breaking up into pieces like the cheap
stuff that you can buy you know you can
go on and on and on with examples like
this you find out in part who you are
through what you consume but you also
produce you're also part of this circuit
of production and circulation according
to Hegel at least so he says we have a
general activity going on here and then
he says the actual has simply the
spiritual significance of being
immediately universal
so there's universality again on both
sides now here's where it gets really
interesting he brings up each individual
thinking that they're just acting in
their own interest there being a
particular in in participating in the
economy that is creating circulating
consuming wealth but in doing so and he
brought this up much earlier remember
back in the reason section we're talking
about action he says in the in the the
enjoyment he becomes conscious of his
own independent existence and for that
reason does not take it to be something
spiritual yet when looked at from an
external point of view it's evident that
each in his own enjoyment provides
enjoyment for all just as in working for
himself he is at the same time working
for all and all are working for him we
are connected through this economic
activity activities right not simply
production but consumption think about
for example a restaurant you go in you
sit down you're shown to your table the
server comes tells you about the
specials no no you just want to eat
order something off the menu you order
it somebody in the back is producing it
they bring it out you start consuming it
hopefully not just you know shoveling it
into your mouth but consuming it first
with your
eyes and then with you know your your
nose your mouth you eat fairly slowly
you enjoy the meal though the server
comes by can see that you're actually
enjoying the food that's been prepared
goes back to the cook cook wants to know
or chef or whoever what did they think
of it oh they seem to be enjoying it
enjoyment is not just one's own pure
individual activity it involves others
it could be antagonistic of course right
you know you're the you're the jerk who
people don't want to see coming in the
door they spit in your food if you do
enjoy it they're not enjoying the fact
that you're enjoying it you know and and
and so on but Hegel's point here is that
there is a kind of spread into something
like universality in our enjoyment in
our production even when we think we're
being just completely self-centered
we're serving some other purposes in
purchasing I am keeping the economy
going
now I'm also of course doing other
things you know that he's not
particularly concerned about here
perhaps contributing to misery in some
other place ruining the environment you
know driving somebody out of business if
I buy everything from these these huge
conglomerates like you know Walmart or
Amazon or you know whatever Google is
selling or Microsoft or Apple you know
you put those those five together and
you've got you know a significant
portion of the US economy right if I'm
only purchasing from those perhaps I am
shortchanging somebody else but that's
not a question that Hegel is considering
at this point he wants our focus to be
on the fact that in both of these we
have some sort of Universal going on so
he says his being for himself is
therefore in itself Universal and
self-interest is merely something in his
mind something he tells himself
something that cannot get as far as
making a reality of what it means
to do to do something that would not
benefit all so we have the individual
poised between these two and now we need
to look at this dynamic a little bit
more closely
in these two spiritual powers then
self-consciousness recognizes its
substance content and purpose in them it
beholds its dual nature in one it sees
what it implicitly is in the other one
is it isn't explicitly for itself but it
is at the same time qua spirit the
negative unity of their subsistence and
of the separation of individuality from
the universal or of actuality and the
self Dominion and wealth therefore
confront the individual as objects that
is as things from which he knows himself
to be free and between which he believes
you can choose or even choose neither as
is free and pure consciousness he
confronts the essence of something which
is merely for him he has them the
essence qua essence within himself in
this pure consciousness the moments of
substance are for him not state power
and wealth but the thoughts of good and
bad but further self-consciousness is
the relation of its pure consciousness
to its actual consciousness of what is
in the form of thought to what exists
objectively it is essentially judgment
it is true that the immediate
determinations of the two sides of
objective reality have already made
clear which is good and which is bad the
good is state power the bad is wealth
but this first judgment cannot be
regarded as a spiritual judgment for in
it one side has been determined only as
a being in itself or as the positive the
other only is of being for itself and as
the negative but as spiritual essences
each is the inter fusion of both moments
and is therefore not exhausted in those
determinations and self consciousness
which is self related is both in and for
itself it must therefore be related to
each determination in a two-fold manner
with the result of their nature which
consists in being self alienated
determinations will be brought to light
in paragraph 495 Hegel is going to
reintroduce these concepts of good and
bad understood as the objects for pure
self-consciousness but now also the
objects of the judgment made by
self-consciousness of state power and
wealth respectively as the good and the
bad and we're going to see this carry
through in the dialectic that's going to
occur in the next you know number of
paragraphs where we begin with state
power as the good and eventually we're
gonna see that that it's not really such
and there's already some of this duality
built in if we jump to the very end you
know he says that each of these
spiritual essences you know state power
and wealth each is the inter fusion of
both moments therefore not exhausted in
these determinations self consciousness
is really the Nexus that is holding them
together because self consciousness
which is self related is both in and for
itself and it's going to be related to
both of these determinations good and
bad made of wealth and state power in a
as Hegel is gonna say twofold manner
this is what allows there to be a
dialectical progression but let's see
where he first begins with this
paragraph and then how we get to that
that ending point for the paragraph
which is definitely not the ending point
for what what's going to be happening in
the rest of this section so he says that
in these two spiritual powers self
consciousness recognizes and here Hegel
uses three terms one right after the
other very important it's substance just
the cognate substance right content in
halt and purpose Beck so he doesn't say
self consciousness finds these in only
one state power or in wealth he says it
finds them in find this these important
aspects of itself in in both of these
two and it has a choice to make between
them
so he goes on and he says in them it
beholds its dual nature that is the
human being can be aligned with either
of these wealth or state power economic
activity political activity an economic
way of looking at things a political way
of looking at things
he said says in one it sees what
implicitly is that is state power what
is in itself on Zeke in the other it
sees what is for another right in the
other what is explicitly for itself and
he says but it is at the same time the
negative unity of their subsistence and
of the separation of individuality from
the universal or the actuality and the
self so what's really the bridge between
these is the individual self
consciousness or more properly
individual self consciousness in the
plural that's what allows there to be
any connection between state power which
lacking any individual consciousnesses
wouldn't even exist with it with well
which again lacking any individual
consciousnesses would not exist both of
these the public you could say the
public and the private however you want
to put it the in itself and the for
itself
they can't exist without these self
conscious individual as their mediator
and the self conscious mediator in this
case becomes aware to a certain extent
that they can make a choice on the
choice Hegel says very interestingly is
not just well either you get a choose
state power or you go choose well you
could choose neither you could say screw
em both I'm gonna make my own way I'm
gonna withdraw from society man and find
myself an island and knit myself you
know stuff out of I don't know coconuts
or whatever it is people do write bark
from trees I'll fish and do all that
sort of stuff
that's a possibility dialectics not
gonna advance with with anything like
that well you know that's an opt-out is
certainly an option
right so Hegel goes on and he says as
this pure and free consciousness he
confronts the essence as something which
is merely for him he has then the
essence qua essence within himself self
consciousness becomes aware of the fact
that it can choose between these and can
choose for neither right so here we
become aware of a kind of central
freedom
now there's another movement to the
bringing back in the good and the bad
Hegel says in this pure consciousness
that is the consciousness of that
freedom the moments of substance are for
him not state power and wealth anymore
but the thoughts of good and bad then he
says further self-consciousness is the
relation of it's pure consciousness
whose actual consciousness the form of
thought to what exists objectively and
Hegel says this is essentially judgment
what is going on when we engage in
judgment we are connecting up the pure
consciousness and the actual
consciousness we are connecting up the
realm of thought and the realm of
objectivity not usually the way we think
of judgment is it but this is how Hegel
is doing it here and that judgment could
be that something is bad or that
something is good and the judgments in
this case Hegel sort of takes that it's
kind of obvious that the state power is
going to be cast as the good one joj
does the good one and the wealth part is
going to be judged as bad
why because state power is seems to be
more universal it's the whole society
whereas wealth is just you know
individuals here and there exchanging
things with each other self-interest
that sort of thing I mean in our society
I suppose we could say we have
ideologies that's the exact opposite
where state powers the big baddie right
and wealth is the good
economic exchange or something like that
so he says it's true that immediate
determinations of the two sides of
objective reality have already made
clear which is good which is bad the
good is state power the bad is well he
says this first judgment that is that
the the state power is good cannot be
regarded as a spiritual judgment for in
it one side has been determined only as
a being in itself
as the positive right the other is being
for itself and as the negative so we
have positive and negative then this
this first judgment and this is a
judgment that I think many people would
make and it is a judgment that
historically did tend to get made so I
think Hegel's got a good basis for this
now where is Hegel gonna go from this
well this is where we got to the the end
he says look you know you can't it's not
as simple as saying positive negative
good and bad because both of these end
up being an inter fusion of both moments
you know let's put it to you this way I
don't want to give you too much of the
story that's coming up you don't get
state power without the involvement of
wealth it's never so pure and simple as
that right state power is always
entwined with wealth likewise you don't
get a pure sort of circulation of
productivity and consumption and all
that without state power being involved
in some way and you don't get either of
these without the individuals being
involved in them as well so the question
going forward is how are all of these
going to be connected with each other
and what sort of conclusions should we
draw what are we learning in the process
and remember to that Hegel views this as
a process of historical development of
consciousness something is being learned
on the way not just for us the
phenomenologist who are studying this
we're watching it but with in history
for human consciousness